l'image est saisissante un chevalier du
moyen-âge qui déambulent en armure sur
la route 138 il s'agit d'une performance
de l'artiste français abraham poincheval
dans une chaleur suffocante et sous 34
kg de métal ce chevalier a accompli
dimanche matin sa quête en parcourant la
dernière étape du périple qui l'a mené
de montréal à québec une marche de 280
kilomètres réalisés en dix jours et il
ya un peu de tension en fait de savoir
qu'on arrête qu'on va arriver que la
pièce va se terminer là et voilà en fait
il ya de l'émotion aussi parce que c'est
quand même
c'est pas c'est pas très loin c'est pas
non plus tout proche mais on a
l'impression qu'on a fait un vrai saut
dans le temps c'était là l'un des
objectifs du performeur
pluridisciplinaire rapprocher le présent
et le passé en empruntant une des plus
anciennes routes du québec le chemin du
roy c'est aussi le point de départ d'une
réflexion sur la technologie et les
déplacements c'était de revêtir en fait
cette karatas technologique oc et puis
un peu
de ferraille et un peu avec avec tous
les véhicules tous les chars convoitant
de nuque en fait qu'ils sont aussi
finalement descente d'are murs du 21e
siècle l'artiste cinquantenaire
originaire de marseille n'en est pas à
sa première prouesse il a déjà passé
plusieurs jours enfermée dans une roche
ou encore dans un ours en paille et le
chevalier errant l'homme sent ici est
une performance ou la douleur était bien
présente elle a un côté beaucoup plus et
beaucoup plus physique il faut réussir à
endurer hand c'est le plus difficile je
pense était hier avec la très haute
chaleur qu'on a eus avec des côtes assez
forte
voilà où là on al'impression de cuir
sous l'armure dans sa démarche abraham
poincheval joue beaucoup sur
l'étonnement et l'incrédulité que
peuvent susciter les scènes artistiques
qu'ils imaginent à saissac à ces cas
c'est fou je trouve c'est comment on
crée cette petite capsule tout à coup de
magie dans un quotidien le chevalier a
été accueilli en héros au centre d'art
le lieu dans saint-roch c'est là qu'il
s'est défait de son armure elle est
désormais l'une des pièces de
l'exposition retraçant le périple
d'abraham poincheval